[Music]
and you get to a point as a quarterback
but you can read a guy's body language
that's where the chemistry is they they
fake a corner blitz
[Music]
the strike is right they talk about it
this vision and ability to feel and see
the field feels pressure understands
coverage at the controls with Damien
Harris behind him
[Applause]
they might go for one right here and he
will much like the championship game
was the same pattern Gary but it sure
looks similar they opted to do it on
second down they run herb Smith he grabs
that safety and as a result you have one
on wall on a post over the top with
Jerry Judy born 50-plus and both games
they've never started a year with three
straight 50-point games
[Applause]
test
but I put this on CJ more the other
safety over the top
[Music]
[Applause]
Henry wrong touchdown with nick saban
that gravitate till Tim step away from
me mixes everybody runs away
[Applause]
other second places
[Applause]
and watch he knows it's bearing down on
a sack right here he lets it go at the
last second when he knows he's got the
touchdown and runs gets one and he took
a shot he Harris in the back seat of the
bow with to the town of the law
[Applause]
there's deeply
strike
[Applause]
Judis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
watch it move to the outside
then decides to come in come in then
comes in and hits him low
did you see him the reaction
the crowd is him dropping off
comes in at food got loose in the end
zone
[Music]